The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Welcome back.
Well, sorry, I wasn't here.
It's more dramatic
for me, I guess,
than if I had been
here on Tuesday.
I hope John did a good
job covering for me.
I'm sure he did.
So you've learned
about walking robots.
You've learned about
lots of robots.
You learned a handful of
very powerful techniques,
I think, for designing
motions for these robots.
Some of my favorite these days
are things like the dir call
type methods.
So let's consider the problem
of taking some robot described
by our standard, some
non-linear dynamics form,
and taking that robot from
an initial condition x0
and getting it to
some final condition.
I don't even care
about the time.
So you're just getting it
to some other state, x goal.
So what tools have
we already got
that could help us
drive this system
from some initial condition
to some goal state?
The answer is a lot
of tools, right?
If the state space
is small enough,
you could imagine designing an
optimal control cost function
that we could do
dynamic programming on.
That would get us to that goal
if we only rewarded ourselves
from being away from the goal.
We could do a shooting
method, right?
If we're using our
SQP, our SNOPT type
interface to the
shooting methods,
then we could provide a
final value constraint, which
says I want the endpoint
of my trajectory
to be exactly at the goal.
And that would solve this
problem in some cases.
But both of those methods
have problems, right?
The DP doesn't scale.
The shooting methods
scale nicely.
But if you ask your
shooting method
to drive you from x0
to x goal, there's
some chance it's going to just
say, I can't do it, right?
I can't satisfy that
constraint because it's
based on a local
gradient optimization.
And if there's local
minima, SNOPT will just say,
I can't satisfy the constraint
x at time final equals x goal,
happens a lot.
If you're looking at hard
enough, interesting enough,
problems, it'll
happen to you, OK?
So what do you do?
Do you just say, oh, find
a new research problem,
tell my advisor I've got
to find something else?
OK, there's more
things you can try.
The methods I want
to talk about today
are the feasible motion
planning algorithms.
So motion planning
is a very broad term.
It's used all the
time in robotics.
I'd say roughly
everything we've done
to date has been a motion
planning algorithm.
It's like saying it's
a control algorithm.
It's a very general term.
Some people debate whether an
algorithm is a motion planning
algorithm or an optimal
control algorithm or whatever.
I think that's sort
of a waste of time.
I would say they're all
motion planning algorithms.
Most of the things we've
talked about so far
I would call optimal motion
planning, where we actually
had a cost function
flying around to do it.
Oftentimes, motion plans
go from a start to a goal.
Oftentimes, they're open loop,
but that's not really defining.
You can do feedback
motion planning.
Motion planing is just
a very general term
saying I'm designing the
motions of my machine.
The reason I want to
use motion planning
in the title for this
lecture and next lecture
is because there's an important
class of motion planning
algorithms that are not
covered by the optimal control
algorithms.
And that's these feasible
motion planning algorithms.
So the optimal motion
planning algorithms
try to get me from x0 to
x goal in some way that's
good as scored by
some cost function.
Feasible motion planning
algorithms aspire to do less.
They just say, I'll get
any trajectory that gets me
from the start to the goal.
Because they surface their
claims on optimality,
oftentimes these
algorithms will work
for more complicated systems.
So the message I want
to sort of deliver today
is that there are a lot of
good feasible motion planning
algorithms out
there in the world.
We'll talk about some of the
most exciting ones, I think.
And actually, even if you
care about optimality,
even if deep down
in your core you
say this is a cost function
that I must optimize for my life
to be complete, you still should
care about feasible motion
planning algorithms because
they can do something
like seed a dir call
method, let's say,
and get it out of local minima.
So let's say I have an Acrobot
that I'm trying to swing up.
And I've got a table right
here, so I can't swing that way.
And whatever my initial
guess at the trajectory,
the system keeps
banging up against this.
It can't figure out a way
to turn around and go back
the opposite way
to get to the top.
Or maybe there's a table that
you have to go through just
at a certain way.
I would say, if
you're shooting method
is having trouble finding
its way to the goal,
maybe you should back
off on optimality.
Just find any old trajectory
that gets to the goal.
And then take that result of
that motion planning algorithm,
hand it to dir call,
and let it then do
the rest of the optimization.
We'll say more about this.
I just wanted to
give you some context
about why we want to talk about
this extra set of algorithms.
In general, we're
going to expect
these to scale to slightly
higher dimensional systems
than the optimal
control algorithms
we've talked about
so far and to be
more global than the
shooting methods.
There's a great book on
all of this stuff called--
I guess it should
be underlined--
Planning Algorithms.
So I just spelled
planning wrong.
So I'm completely
sleep deprived.
If I do stupid things
like that, call them out.
I'll fix them.
Something about kid
number two, the first kid
stays awake while the other
kid sleeps and vice versa.
It just makes it that
much more interesting.
Yeah.
And Planning Algorithms,
the book by Steve LaValle
is actually--
Steve's got it on his
website, the full version.
You can download for free.
So it's nice accessible
text that you
can check out if you like it.
OK.
So before we get into our
first feasible motion planning
algorithm, let me give you
just a little sort of culture.
The motion planning
algorithms, I think,
actually grew up not so much
in the controls community,
but in more the artificial
intelligence community.
And there's a reason for that.
There are serious
people out there
that think the only thing
there is to intelligence
is the ability to do search.
So I think that artificial
intelligence via search,
to some extent,
sounds ridiculous.
But it's pretty hard to
disprove and some people really
think it.
But that's the way it happened.
So let me give you
some cultural examples
of where that came from.
Some of the original efforts
in artificial intelligence,
they thought, my
computer program
will be intelligent
if it can play
a game like checkers or chess.
And as early as the '50s, Art
Samuel was building checker
playing robots that are
basically doing search in order
to try to figure out how to
beat their opponent in chess--
or in checkers, sorry.
Checkers-- Samuel in the '50s.
Chess, we can leap forward
to IBM's Deep Blue,
let's say in the last decade.
These are computer
programs that,
at times, can play with the
sophistication of a trained
human.
And they're based
on simply having
the rules of the
game programmed,
some databases of moves
that they've stored up,
a lot of them in the Deep
Blue case, and search.
Finding the way to move
my robot from x0 to x goal
you can imagine being very, very
analogous to taking my computer
game and finding from an
initial board configuration
to a winning board
configuration.
They're exactly
the same problem.
So because of things
like computer games,
the artificial
intelligence community
really started building up
these search algorithms.
And they were very fundamental.
The other big push, I
think, from the AI community
was in ideas like
theorem proving.
So an AI zealot of
4 years ago might
have told you that mathematics
would be obsolete by now.
Because all you have
to do is program
the basic rules of mathematics
into a set of rules
that your computer
program could evaluate,
and then proving whether
something was true or not
was just a matter of
finding the right chain
of small logical
deductions to put together
to be able to
prove that p equals
np or something like that.
OK.
And actually, I joke, but that's
actually a very powerful thing
that works today.
If you've use
Mathematica or Maple
and you've asked it
to simplify, that's
a result of theorem
proving work that people
did in artificial
intelligence a long time ago.
And again, it's a
matter of designing
the rules of the game, which
is a collection, in that case,
of mathematical
primitives, and finding
a path from your initial
knowledge to some proof,
let's say.
But even going beyond that,
there's people out there that--
my favorite instance
of this is there's
a guy, David Lenat,
who's somewhere in Texas
right now typing--
well, he's got teams of
people typing random factoids
into computers.
He's got this
project called Cyc.
How many people
have heard of Cyc?
Yeah?
So I think this guy
believes that, if I
can get enough people
to type in things like,
dogs chase cats and balloons
go up or something--
I don't know, enough random
factoids into this computer--
and he builds up an
ontology of knowledge
to some big collection of facts
and a good search algorithm
to back it up, that his computer
will achieve intelligence.
It'll be able to
answer any query.
It'll be completely
indistinguishable from a human.
You could ask it any query.
And as long as it's got the
right chain of factoids stored
away and a good search
algorithm behind it,
then this thing is intelligent.
And people have
been typing things
in for a really long time.
You can go, and you can
get the student version
or whatever and
ask it questions.
And you can get a research
version and ask it questions.
And people use it.
And I mean, Google,
I think, works
better because it's
accessing WordNet,
which is basically an
ontology of synonyms
and things like this.
These sound crazy, but
they're the backbone
of some of the things
that you use every day.
OK.
So for whatever reason,
for these kind of reasons,
the search algorithms, the
motion planning algorithms
that we're going to talk
about, which are today
used a lot in robotics, grew
up under the computer science
umbrella under
artificial intelligence.
So the term motion
planning typically
implies that you've got
some dynamical system you're
shoving around, let's say, but
it's clearly just an instance
of this search problem.
When people talk about
motion planning in robotics,
there are problems that
people care about a lot.
A majority of the motion
planning literature in robotics
is concerned with
kinematic motion planning,
often with obstacles
or something like this.
So if I have a robotic arm
with 10 degrees of freedom
and I want to reach through
some complicated geometry
to turn a doorknob or to
reach down and pick up
some part from
assembly, then that's
a complicated geometric problem.
Typically, you assume that the
systems are fully actuated.
You don't worry about actually
handling the trajectory
once you get there.
That's normally assumed away.
And they assume that all
trajectories are feasible.
They're just trying to find
some path through the obstacle
field.
So one of the key
problems that you
can think about in that world
is the piano movers problem.
How many people know the
piano movers problem?
OK.
How many people have ever
moved a couch into a dorm room?
You all know the piano
movers problem then, right?
Basic task is you
have some 3D shape.
You have a bunch of obstacles.
You have to find a position
and orientation trajectory that
will maneuver your big piano
through a world of obstacles.
It's just like going up
the stairs with your couch,
you know, marking the walls and
bending your couch as you go.
And that's sort some of the
driving problems in the motion
planning space.
So it's things like that,
finding a collision-free path
for a complicated geometry
through an obstacle based
environment, just trying to
give you a little culture here.
And in that world, one of
the most important concepts,
I think, is the configuration
space concept, which actually--
you know who came up with
configuration spaces?
He's sitting right upstairs.
It's Tomás Lozano-Pérez
is, I think,
credited with the
configuration space idea.
And the idea is that these
problems can get a lot simpler.
Let's say I have a
square robot going
through some complicated
obstacle field.
And I want to find a path
from some start to the goal.
Well, instead of reasoning about
the geometry of this relative
to the geometry of
this all the time,
the configuration
space tells you
you should actually add
the volume of your robot
to your obstacles coming up with
configuration space obstacles.
If you actually add the
volume of your robot
to the obstacles--
I'm doing this very
hand-waving here.
But then you can
turn the problem
of finding a big geometry
through another geometric field
to taking a point and driving
it through the geometric field.
And that's a critical,
critical idea
in the world of kinematic
motion planning.
We don't really care about
kinematic motion planning
in this class.
We've got enough troubles
without obstacles.
We just care about having an
interesting dynamic system
to move around.
So the things we're
talking about in this class
fall under the heading
kinodynamic motion planning.
And of course, the nonholonomic
motion planning ideas
are very related, too.
We care about the dynamics.
We care about things
that are forced
to follow some trajectories,
like nonholonomic systems are,
too.
So if you're out there seeing
papers and talks and everything
by motion planning, I just
want you to sort of see
that they're certainly related
to the optimal control things
we've talked about.
But sometimes they
let go of optimality.
They're often about
kinematics, but there's
a good subset of them
which is thinking
about exactly the
problems we care about
with this kinodynamic
motion planning.
Excellent.
OK.
So now, let's do
some motion planning.
Culture is there.
When we did dynamic
programming, I already
sort of forced upon you the
idea that we could potentially,
at great cost, discretize our
system and state and actions
potentially.
So let's do the same
thing when we start off
with motion planning and
start with discrete planning
algorithms.
Let's say we've got our phase
plot of our simple pendulum.
For kicks right now,
let's just start off
with the trivial
discretization, let's say.
We're going to bin up
our space like this,
call each one of
those a state and try
to start talking about a
graph-based representation
of the dynamics of the system
that tries to find a path,
let's say, from our initial
state to some goal state.
This isn't the only way
to do discretization,
but it's a good way to
start thinking about it.
So that turns the problem
into some graphical model,
where the control actions
determine our state
transitions.
I like to actually call them
s and a in the discrete world.
So people know a lot about
doing search on a graph.
I don't want to
bore you with it,
but I want you to at least
know the algorithms that
are out there and be
able to call upon them
if they become useful.
So let's see we've butchered
up our system like this,
and we want to find a path from
some starting discrete state
to some goal state with a
discrete set of actions.
How can we do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] search
algorithm, like A star.
RUSS TEDRAKE: A star
is a perfect example.
Yeah.
Dynamic programming
is on the table, too.
Dynamic programming,
that's actually the way I--
the reason I drew
that picture before
is because we talked
about that as a way
to think about
dynamic programming.
In dynamic programming
is incredibly
efficient if what you care about
is knowing the optimal feedback
policy, how to get to the goal
from every possible initial
state.
I mean, the problem
with that is,
if you have to look at
every single initial state,
then it's not going to scale the
high dimensions because there's
going to be a lot of states.
If you have a slightly higher
dimensional system and you want
to find a start to the goal,
but just a single path--
you don't care about
every possible state--
then you can do not better
than dynamic programming.
But you can be more selective
with your dynamic programming
algorithm by doing
these Dijkstra type
and A star type algorithms.
So let me just sort
of do that quickly,
so you know that that's there.
So dynamic programming,
again, it's very efficient.
It goes to a global optima.
Typically, DP is used
to describe the version
where you're trying to solve
for every state simultaneously.
You can do a bit better,
you can be more selective,
if you just care about from a
start to a goal, like 0 to xg.
It's actually a
little bit surprising
to say that I can actually find
my path from a start to a goal
and know that I'm
at a global optima
without ever expanding
every single node.
And then sometimes we don't even
care about optimality at all.
Like I said, some
of these algorithms
are just trying to find
any old path to the goal,
and then you can
certainly imagine
finding your path to the
goal without expanding
every possible node.
They all have a
very simple recipe.
Basically, you keep a
prioritized Q. How many people
know what a prioritized Q is?
I should say it's often
called Q, but it means queue.
It's another sleep
deprivation thing there.
So a prioritized queue
is a data structure
that we use in computer science
that I'll describe quickly
here.
So we basically
have a list of nodes
that we want to
consider expanding
next stored in some
list, but they're
stored in that list in an
ordered fashion, ordered
by how likely it is that we
want to check that node next.
Depending on the ways
that you add nodes
into the prioritized
queue, you can
do any number of the standard
algorithms, the breadth
first search, the
depth first search.
Dijkstra's, let me make
sure I spell it right.
D-J-I, right?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: D-I-J.
RUSS TEDRAKE: D-I-J?
OK, good.
Thanks.
And you could do A star.
There's more.
There's iterative
deepening, things like this.
They all go basically like this.
I have a queue of things
I'm about to explore.
I start off with
the starting state.
I put that in my queue.
Next step of the algorithm--
take something out
of the queue.
Consider its children.
And then take the first one out
of my priority queue, repeat.
If I consider the
children in a first
in, first out kind of way,
if I add nodes and just say,
as soon as I pick up a
node, I'm going to go ahead
and stick those nodes into my
queue in a sort of a first in,
first out kind of way,
then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to proceed to look
for the goal by going here,
then here, then here, then here,
then here, right down the tree.
That's a breadth first search.
If I do a prioritized queue
where, when I add the children,
I just do a last in, first
out, then I'll go here.
Then I'll go here.
Then I'll go here, and I'll
go as deep down the tree
as I could possibly
do before I come back
and go down to the other nodes.
If I keep along,
let's call it, a cost
to come to differentiate
it from the cost to go,
if I keep a record of how much
cost I incurred for my cost
function getting to
that node and I always
select to expand
the node that would
be the cheapest, then that's
called Dijkstra's algorithm.
It's exactly equivalent
to dynamic programming,
but it's in the forward sense.
And then A star is
an even nicer way
to do that, which
combines a cost
to come plus some heuristic.
My goal is to make sure you
guys know these are out there.
There's lots of good
easy places to read
about these
algorithms, especially
Steve LaValle's book.
The only surprising thing
really about these algorithms
is, first of all, that you
can often very efficiently
find your way to the goal
without expanding as many nodes
as you might think.
A star, in particular, if you
can find a good heuristic--
a heuristic, in this case, is
an estimate of the cost to go,
a guess at your value function.
If you can guess your value
function in a way where you
always underestimate it-- again,
I'm not going to bore you with
all the details here--
then actually you can
sometimes expand very few nodes
and find your way
right to the goal.
They're very
efficient algorithms.
People out here use
A star all the time.
For the Grand Challenge,
I think half the teams
had A star planners
running on their vehicle.
For LittleDog, we're picking
footholds to get from the start
to the goal.
We have an A star planner in
there, discrete time planners.
These things are real.
They're good.
They're fast.
If you can find
a good heuristic,
they can be very,
very efficient.
If you care about a continuous
time, a continuous state,
continuous action plan
that gets me from the goal,
then they're not as
satisfying because they
relied on this discretization.
So we know, when we're
discretizing this thing,
we're going to
have some problems.
I'm going to just assume that
there's a control action that
gets me sort of
squarely in the center
of this next discretized
cell and then go like this.
If I were to execute
out my actions
from my discrete
planning algorithm
on the continuous
time system, I'm
going to quickly
deviate from my plan.
But these things
are an excellent way
to start to seed something like
a direct co-location method.
Find yourself a
feasible optimal plan.
And then stabilize it, let's
say, with the LTV feedback.
Good.
So that world of planning
algorithms is out there.
But about, I don't
know, 10 years ago
now, something big happened
in the robotic motion planning
world.
People started using
sample-based motion planning
algorithms.
And there was sort of a
revolution in people using
motion planning in robotics.
It's also sometimes called
randomized motion planning.
And these are we
are going to dig
a little deeper in because
we use them all the time.
I think they're an important
class of algorithms.
So two of the most notable
sample-based motion planning
ideas are the rapidly
exploring randomized trees
and the probabilistic roadmap.
Another poll, how many
people know about RRTs?
Awesome.
How many people know about PRMs?
OK.
They're pretty
related to each other.
Let's talk about rapidly
exploring randomized trees
first.
So both of these are
an attempt to get away
from these very coarse
discretizations like this
and sort of embrace the
fact that we're working
in a continuous state space.
Instead of discretizing
it at some known sites,
we're going to discretize sort
of at randomly chosen samples.
And as we add more
and more samples,
we're going to worry less and
less about the discretization.
And eventually,
we're going to have
something nice to say
about the continuous space.
So the rapidly exploring
randomized trees, the RRTs,
are a very simple
algorithm to explain.
Let's think about it in terms of
moving a 2D piano through a 2D
world in configuration space.
So we've got a point
moving through a world.
It should really
be 3D, actually,
if there's an
orientation to the piano.
But let's just look at
the 2D problem here.
So I've got a point,
an official state,
an initial goal in a 2D world.
Let's call it xy.
And I've got some obstacles.
I'd like to find a path
from the start to the goal
without explicitly
discretizing the space.
The RRTs do it like this.
Pick a point from
random in the space.
Try to connect your
current tree, which
in the initial state is just
this x0, to that new point.
Let's make it exactly
clear that I can't do that.
My attempt to
directly connect this
is going to fail because it
goes through an obstacle.
So I can't add that node.
Sample again randomly.
At some point, I'll
get a node, like, here.
I'm going to make
a branch of my tree
that connects those two points.
Pick a new random point.
Let's say you get
something here.
Now, you have to choose between
these two random points,
decide which is the closest.
The closest isn't
always an easy thing
to decide if you have
complicated dynamics.
In this problem,
it's pretty easy.
We could just use something
like a Euclidean distance.
And I'll connect
it up like this.
I get another random point.
I connect it up like this.
I get some random points
that go whatever way.
If they end up here,
I just throw them out.
If they end up something
that I can't connect,
I'll just throw it out.
But at some point, I'll
start filling the space
with these trees.
Lo and behold, if
I do it enough,
it doesn't actually
necessarily take that
long until I get up here and
get close in the vicinity
of that goal, very
simple random algorithm.
Do you understand how
it's sort of avoiding
the curse of discretization?
It's just picking
points at random
from this continuous space.
So there's no constraints,
no explicit constraints
that it lies in the
center of some bucket
or something like that.
Nodes could be arbitrarily
close to each other.
I can get arbitrarily fine
sort of discretization.
What's really cool, what
makes these things tick,
is that the idea is so simple.
The code is so easy to write.
And they really,
really work fast.
Let me just show you
that basic example.
This time, I'm going to do it
even without any obstacles,
but just to show
you the basic growth
of these kind of planners.
Awesome.
OK.
So my initial condition
is just that blue point.
And I'm going to start growing a
tree in every random direction.
There's not even a
goal in this problem.
This is just to show you the
basic growth of the tree.
Every point I grow at
random, every time I
pick a point from a uniform
distribution covering
the space, I'm going to find the
closest point in the algorithm,
a closest point on the tree.
And I'm going to try to grow
my tree towards that node.
Yeah.
Sort of understand
what's happening there?
It's pretty faint,
I think, but--
all right.
So watch what happens
if I just let that run.
OK.
Trivial algorithm, it
has what a lot of people
like to call a fractal
expansion of the coverage area.
Of course, if there's
obstacles, it'll
take a little longer
to get around there,
but the algorithm
probabilistically
covers the state space as
I add more and more points.
Some people call them dense
trees because they do this.
If you noticed
something about them,
they have sort of
surprisingly nice qualities.
It filled the space pretty
uniformly pretty quickly.
It didn't just go
off in one corner
and start adding nodes on one
side or something like that.
It actually has a property that
people call the Voronoi bias.
The Voronoi bias
implies that the tree
has a bias for always
growing into the biggest
open regions of the graph.
And that just comes
from sampling uniformly.
If I have some tree that
has a big, wide open area
for whatever region, then
with very high probability
I'm going to pick a point that's
inside the biggest region.
And the biggest
regions in the space
are the ones that
have the highest
probability of being chosen.
So probabilistically, this thing
fills the biggest open spaces
in the search tree just by the
virtue of sampling uniformly.
So you get these very,
very dense, fast trees.
And you can imagine, if
there's obstacles or something
like that inside there, it's
going to work its way just
around the obstacles.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it
slow down as you get
more and more nodes in there?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So what is the computation
that goes into it?
What's the expensive part of
the computation would you guess?
AUDIENCE: Finding
the nearest neighbor.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Nearest
neighbor-- good.
So, yeah, it slows down
with the nearest neighbor,
but not as much as you expect.
Actually, there's
two expensive parts.
Only the nearest neighbor
one shows up here.
The other one, potentially,
is the collision checker.
And in some complicated
systems, checking
if you're inside a
region, especially
if you're a big robotic
arm or something like that,
can be actually the
dominant, expensive thing.
So these things, in MATLAB,
everything's vectorized.
It actually doesn't grow that
badly with the number of nodes,
but certainly the nearest
neighbor calculation
gets more and more expensive.
By default, it's just
checking the sample point
at every possible node.
AUDIENCE: You could use
a k-d tree or something.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, good.
Yeah.
So there are different
sort of structures
that you can use to make
that look-up more efficient.
So RRTs have kind of come in
and done things to robotics
that people hadn't done before.
So this is a
two-dimensional example.
People would have said before,
I can do sort of motion planning
effectively and maybe 5 or 10
dimensions, a little bit more
than I could do with just
DP, but not a lot more.
Because I'm still doing these
sort of random factorizations.
The guys that came out and
started doing these RRTs--
LaValle being one of them,
Kuffner being another one--
started showing
examples of robots
with 32 degrees of freedom
doing pretty complicated plans.
See if I have that
Kuffner video there.
It's an animated GIF.
This is H7 at the time.
This was the University of Tokyo
humanoid entry before everybody
started giving out ASIMOs.
A little before Honda started
giving out ASIMOs this is.
And it's doing things
like taking that 32
degree of freedom robot, finding
a plan to have it bend down
and pick up a flashlight
under the table.
And that sort of shocked people.
Now, people have gone off
and used RRTs to do things
like protein folding.
It's was a pretty hot topic in
the motion planning community
and these other very high
complexity geometric planning
problems that people
just haven't done before.
But even this guy, even
though it's a robot,
his feet are flat
on the ground, yeah?
And they're still
just assuming that you
can search in position
space and then find
some controller
that'll stabilize it.
So they're not doing the
underactuated planning example.
All right, so I wouldn't
be talking about it
if I didn't think
it was relevant
for underactuated planning.
So let's show you
the basic story here.
What happens if we do
it on a simple pendulum?
There we go.
So you see, I'm plotting
only every 30 nodes
or something like that.
I pick a point at random.
I start growing the tree.
The way I grew the
tree, now, is I
don't go all the
way towards the goal
because I can't necessarily go
all the way towards the goal.
I just take a step in the
direction of the goal.
How do I take a step in
the direction of the goal?
I just try five random
actions, let's say,
and pick the one that
got closest to the goal.
So if you look closely,
every time it expands a node,
you'll see a bunch of
different arrows coming out.
And it picked the one that got
closest to that random sample
point.
And it's still just using
the Euclidean distance
to try to find the
closest neighbor.
This one I think I wasn't
careful about doing
the terminal condition.
But I want you to see what the
most important thing about this
is, what do you see in
that plot besides a mess
as it gets adding more and more?
What I see is I see the
fundamental structure
of the pendulum.
I see these spiral trajectories.
It's amazing to me that trivial
randomized algorithms like this
can probe the basic dynamics
of my underactuated system.
All right, so if you see the
algorithm is, now, very simple.
So I pick a point at random.
That's actually a good
example I just happened upon.
Pick a point at random.
The red is my
random sample plane.
The blue is the closest plane
in the tree in the Euclidean
sense.
It happens to be a horrible
choice for the closest
point on the tree
in the dynamic sense
because I know, in state
space, my dynamics can only
go that way.
So really, I'd like to have
picked a point back there that
was farther and Euclidean
distance, but closer
sort of in dynamic distance.
And I'll actually
talk more next lecture
about how you could do that.
But from that note, I
try 10 different actions,
see where it would
have taken me,
and pick the one that ended up
closest in Euclidean distance,
which happens to have been the
one that happened horizontally.
That's enough to let
this thing just sort
of spread itself
out into the world
like a disease or something,
just covering the space
and probing the
dynamics of the system.
And you wait until you
get close to the goal.
RRTs are very, very
powerful way, now,
to start trying to find
reasonable plans on a robot.
That's the vanilla
RRT algorithm.
There's a lot of ways you
can quickly improve them.
And actually, any of the
graph-based search algorithms
do this.
So if I wanted to do
some simple things to try
to speed up that algorithm,
what might you suggest?
There's a couple of reasons
why it felt inefficient.
One of them is
because it's not doing
a very nice job of chasing these
sort of intermediate goals,
like that example showed.
The other thing is it
seems like it's not really
making any effort to
go towards the goal.
So there's a handful
of heuristics
that people use to
make these things tick.
One of them is a goal bias.
I mean, there's lots of
ways to implement it.
The standard way to
implement it is with,
let's say, probability of 0.5
or something like that, 0.05,
choose my random
sample to be the goal.
Otherwise, my random sample is
just the uniform distribution.
That would certainly
encourage the system
to find its way to the goal
a lot more efficiently.
What's another possible
way to speed this up?
AUDIENCE: Bidirectional.
RUSS TEDRAKE:
Bidirectional, yeah.
In fact, all of the search
techniques, the breadth
versus depth versus A star
on discrete graph searches,
a lot of times one of the
standard things people
do is they'll do
a backward search.
While you're growing out from
the start towards the goal,
you might as well start from
the goal and go backwards.
The problem with
this is it feels
like you're trying to find
a needle in a haystack.
If you can grow a tree in
both directions, then at least
you got a lot of
needles to look for.
And you just wait till the
trees come fairly close.
And even backward search
sometimes by itself
can be faster.
It depends on the system.
AUDIENCE: Is that
because, if your goal is
an unstable point [INAUDIBLE],,
it's more likely to find it?
Is that intuitively
what happens?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Why
sometimes a backward search
would work better?
AUDIENCE: In cases
like underactuated.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's a
really good question.
AUDIENCE: Because you
might have trouble
going to some type of fixed
point, but that for sure
already starts you out there.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I won't
put my weight behind it,
but that sounds like a
pretty good explanation.
In practice, we always
do bidirectional trees.
AUDIENCE: Even when
you want to do both,
you never just go backwards.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: But certainly,
in the kinematic case,
you could definitely
imagine cases where
the backwards could be faster.
Let's say it's hiding
in some little island,
and you just want to get out.
And that's much easier
than finding your way
into the island, let's say.
So certainly, we've
noticed sensitivities
to growing RRTs around
very unstable fixed points.
And it might be
exactly what you said.
It might be.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is the Euclidean
norm the best measure for this?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
The Euclidean norm is a
horrible metric for this.
What do you think would
be a better metric?
AUDIENCE: Energy or
times [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
So energy's a good candidate.
In fact, I think, depending on
what we put on the problem set,
we might ask you to try
an energy metric to do it.
So almost everybody says
this would work better
with a better distance metric.
And almost nobody can tell
you a better distance metric
for these kind of systems.
So we actually have
a couple of ideas
that we've been
working on in lab.
Elena has been working on some
LQR-based distance metrics,
for instance.
So what did you just say?
You said time to arrival.
How would you compute
a time to arrival?
AUDIENCE: You have to
do a moment in time.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Muscle control.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
you just guessed
the one that's one of
my favorites right now.
So one idea here,
not fully proven yet,
but it's still in the oven
here is that, every time,
I pick a random sample
point I'll linearize
the system around that point.
Say that's a cartoon
of a linearization.
Compute a LQR
stabilizer around this.
And then use the value function
for a minimum time problem.
So compute a min time LQR
actually around this point.
And then use the value function
as the distance metric.
So I like that idea a lot.
There's a couple
subtleties that go into it.
So when you pick a random
point in state space,
if it's got a velocity or--
most points you pick
randomly in states space
are not stabilizable.
So you can't do an infinite
horizon minimum time LQR.
You have to do a finite horizon
and then potentially search
over horizon times, but
you can do that, actually,
pretty efficiently.
The other issue about
it is that it's actually
not a proper distance metric.
Why is it not a proper
distance metric?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: It
doesn't [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I think--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It probably doesn't follow
the triangle inequality.
It doesn't even have symmetry.
If I were to linearize
around this point
and compute its distance,
linearize around this point,
there just absolutely
no guarantees
that it would be the same.
But I don't care
about that actually.
I just have to put
it in the paper.
As long as it works, right?
It's also more
expensive a little bit,
but it can make a
dramatic improvement
in the way it spreads.
There's another idea.
I was actually planning
to talk about some
of the more subtle
ideas next time.
But since we're at it,
the other way to do it
is to change the
sampling distribution.
So Alec Shkolnik in our group
has got a very clever way
to grow these trees, where it
uses a sampling metric that
doesn't try to go
where it can't go.
Let me see if I can say
that more carefully.
I told DARPA about
it three days ago.
So I just want to
show you the picture.
OK.
So this is Alec's algorithm for
being more clever at expanding.
He changes the bias to the point
where this is the tree we just
saw it, basically, right?
And his new tree
looks like that.
So it looks pretty compelling.
How did he do it?
He does this thing he calls
reachability guided RRTs.
Every time he expands
a node, he also
expands what would happen if
I had applied maximum torque
and minimum torque.
So he expands a couple
nodes that represent
a cone of feasibility.
The algorithm turns
out to be trivial.
So now, I take my
Euclidean distance metric
or whatever it is, pick
my random sample point.
If the closest point is one of
these boundary feasible things,
that means there's
room to grow the tree.
If the closest
point, however, is
one of the nodes
in my actual graph,
that means I'm not feasible.
I said that quickly.
But long story short,
there's a trivial check here,
which effectively changes
your sampling distribution
just by saying sample a point.
If the closest point on there is
not one of my boundary regions,
but one of my normal
tree elements,
then I know I can't grow there.
And if I get that, I just
throw that point away,
pick another point.
What that does is it
effectively changes
the sampling distribution
to be the green region.
It just throws out all
these unnecessary points
that you can't get towards
and changes your sampling
distribution, so
it's only trying
to grow in places that
it can actually go,
to where the trees got a
chance of growing towards.
So I think the
world is still sort
of small enough that
people are still
finding pretty clever little
tricks to the RRTs that
make them grow a lot better in
constrained systems like this.
So that happens to be,
I think, a very good one
for our kind of problems.
But it also points out
what RRTs are bad at.
So what kind of problems would
you expect an RRT to work on?
And what would you not
expect an RRT to work on?
The classic case of something
you shouldn't expect
an RRT to do very well on is
something that looks like this,
let's say.
x start is over here.
x goal is over here.
And my obstacles look like this.
In general, I think
it's fair to say RRTs
don't like tunnels and tubes.
What's going to
happen if I run my RRT
on this sort of a system?
So you know, I got my tree here.
Pick a point here, fine.
Pick a point here, I'll
quickly cover this area.
Pick a point here,
I throw it away.
Pick a point right
here, can't get to it.
It doesn't do me any good.
You know, after a very
long time, maybe I luck out
and I pick a point here, right?
But then I have to wait,
and I pick point here.
I can't get to it.
You know, I'm just
completely hopeless.
If it's in
two-dimensional space,
then you can imagine sort
of getting lucky enough
or designing a sampling
distribution that does this.
But let's say it's in
some 14-dimensional space
that you have no idea where
the tunnels, the tubes, are.
There are some problems
where RRTs just choke.
AUDIENCE: So in general,
when there's basic solutions,
feasible solutions, it's small?
It's that fair to say?
Because this is a very small
set of [INAUDIBLE] space.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's a little
hard to say that, right?
Because, I mean, lots of
trajectories work, right?
This one works this.
This works, you know?
But I think, when
there's narrow passages,
I think that's a more clear
way to say it when it chokes.
AUDIENCE: And so
when you say chokes,
it means it's, as
times goes to infinity,
it'll finally find it.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It is [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So these algorithms, mostly
what you look for in a planning
algorithm is completeness.
You want to know that, as
you expand all the nodes,
eventually if there's
a path to the goal,
you'll find the
path to the goal.
And even if there's
not a path, it'll
tell you there's no path, right?
RRTs have probabilistic
completeness guarantees.
They say, if you expand
enough nodes, then
with the probability
one, if there is a path,
you'll find it.
Probabilistic completeness
doesn't do as much
for disproving the
existence of a path.
It would take a very
long time to disprove it.
But probabilistically,
these things
will find a path to
the goal if it exists.
That's good.
Maybe that'll make you
sleep better at night.
But if you have to
wait for something
to be probabilistically
complete,
it's not going to be useful.
The reason these things
are used like crazy
is that, in practice,
they're very fast.
They can be very, very fast
for finding good solutions.
So really, I mean, the
Grand Challenge vehicle
is using RRTs all
the time to consider
possible future paths
along the street,
trying to avoid obstacles.
It's doing it fast enough sort
of in a receding horizon way.
It's always planning
a minute ahead.
I'm not sure exactly what the
window is in driving time.
And it's doing it every DT
roughly, re-computing its plan.
These things can be really,
really fast in practice.
To some extent, the
dynamic constraints
which we're talking
about on the pendulum
are exactly this problem.
Because the pendulum, like
we said, it's coming here.
We know what the phase portrait
of the pendulum look like.
And we know that, if
we're torque limited,
there's only a handful
of places we can go.
To some extent, kinodynamic
constraints, like this,
dynamics can look
exactly like this.
So if you take your
vanilla RRT, you
saw how effectively it
grew on the pendulum.
It took a lot a lot of
nodes to find its way out.
The hope is that we know
enough about this sort
of dynamical system from some
of our other tools, like LQR,
to do distance metric
from tricks like this
that we're effectively
guiding this thing down
the differential
constraint tubes.
AUDIENCE: Have you
had any [INAUDIBLE]
with relaxing the number?
Like, for example, if you have
like a 15-dimensional robot,
you're going to get to
[INAUDIBLE] position.
Can you relax enough
those dimensions
and then use the
rest [INAUDIBLE]
under control in a very
low dimensional space
and then use that
as a [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
Yes.
So Alec also had--
I'll tell you what,
my next slide,
this is Alec's other
thing about planning
in a task space, which is
exactly what you said I think.
There's lots of ways to do it.
And I think Alec found a
really good way to do it.
This is just an example
of a five-link robotic arm
just in configuration space.
They had to find its way from
that endpoint to the goal
endpoint.
So you see at the top,
that little green arm
is the resulting
configuration of the robot.
The standard RRT looked
all over the place
to try to find that solution.
It's a little subtle
how he had to do it.
You had to basically change
the Voronoi bias to live
in the task space,
but still sample
uniformly from the other space.
So that's not enough to
tell you how to do it,
but that's enough to tell you
it's not completely trivial.
Then he found these really,
really elegant solutions
to plan in task space.
And the result, his
sort of killer plot,
is that this is
the number of links
in the robotic arm versus
the number of nodes
it took to find the goal.
And the standard
RRT went like that.
And after 10 links,
it just was hopeless.
With n going to over
1,000 dimensions,
he was just planning in
constant time basically.
So, yeah, there's the
structure in the problems.
We also, using the partial
feedback linearization task
space, have tried doing it
on underactuated systems.
And that sort of works, too.
Yeah.
But it's not the norm, actually.
It's not the accepted
version of the algorithm yet.
RRTs are beautiful
things, right?
They just grow out, find
their way to the goal.
Potentially, a complaint is,
when you're done with it,
you've got the sort of
choppy discretized path
that gets you to the goal.
But then just hand it to
your trajectory optimizer
as an initial condition and
let it smooth it out, still
satisfying obstacle
constraints, torque constraints,
We know how to do that
and smooth it out.
And you've got yourself a
good trajectory that gets
from the start to the goal.
It's a beautiful thing, I mean,
I think to the point where
Tomás Lozano-Pérez invented
configuration space,
did motion planning
for however long.
He actually stopped
robotics, went off
and did computational
biology for a while.
And he says he came back to
robotics just a few years ago
because these kind of algorithms
made a difference to the point
where it was worth doing
motion planning robotics again.
I don't a more dramatic
thing to say than that.
OK.
So next time, I'm going
to go a little bit more
into using these planning
algorithms and also
feedback motion planning
applied to our model systems,
but I don't want to
completely segue.
That's a big idea.
These RRTs-- simple
algorithm, big idea.
I mean, the idea that a
randomized algorithm can
do better than our
explicit algorithms,
it's all these funny things.
There's classes on
randomized algorithms here.
Every once in a while, these
things just really work nicely.
Randomization can help.
And the reason,
roughly, may be is
that it's actually pretty
cheap to pick a sample point.
It's pretty cheap to evaluate
if it's in a collision.
And so why not just pick a lot?
Instead of trying to
reason about the geometry
of your obstacles, building
configuration spaces, that's
hard compared to just saying,
OK, what if my robot was here?
Was that a collision?
Yeah, that's in collision.
OK.
Throw it out.
And just sometimes randomized
algorithms are better.
OK, see you next week.